I have to wind down with you all soon I
could talk about every single frame of
that book that's non-stop because you're
enthusiastic because you're paying
attention this is what you do you see
your your enthusiasm isn't fake I don't
feel like you're a fake presenter here
going like I'm really interested in what
you're doing you're into it and it shows
and it's exciting for us I am the worst
liar in the world any enthusiasm I
express will always be authentic that
paves the way to the last thing I want
to touch on with you Jamie because
clearly I'm very enthusiastic about art
in general but like film and television
is my lifeblood and what I see happening
in the industry right now is absolutely
breaking my heart but I'm trying to keep
my focus on forging forward and how
we'll come out better off ultimately in
the end you're a huge leader in this
industry you also have comic pick comic
pictures what is something that you've
experienced in like I know it's only
been a week since the strike I started
but something you've experienced in the
last week seeing other actors other
writers other people in any single
sector of the industry rally together
that you are eager to get back to work
and apply to your own work as a producer
and a leader in the business okay so I
have a movie out uh in a week and I have
a TV show on the air right now and I
can't talk about them now these are uh
communities of people that I've worked
with hundreds and thousands of people
coming together to make art for you to
enjoy on television and in movies and
we're not talking about it because we
are at a Crossroads in our industry and
there's a great quote
um that that I'm going to blow or I'm
going to interpret that says
civilization flourishes because great
men and women plant trees under the
shade of which they will never stand
that's how it flourishes that's how we
move forward people take stands now for
the future and and we are at a
Crossroads in our industry
technologically and the whole Paradigm
has shifted from what used to be a
traditional business model and it is
gone streaming completely eviscerated
that old idea and the new idea has taken
place and people are making fortunes on
it and denying the artists a chance to
make a living that's where we are it is
a Crossroads we have hit it and this
dual writer's Guild and Screen Actors
Guild strike is to say we are taking
this stand now for the future so our
sacrifices today is for the future of
the Industry future of artists future of
other storytellers and it's just crucial
and I believe in a settlement I believe
that both sides want a settlement
settlements mean nobody's happy and by
the way nobody he's going to be happy
none of us are going to be going yay but
we will get more and what we deserve and
they will give more than they want to
give and that's what's going to happen
when that's going to happen none of us
know but we are here in solidarity I
have my sag shirt wherever I'm going out
in public I'm going to walk around in my
sag shirt but here we're talking about
mother nature for Titan comics and I
felt like I wouldn't you know kind of
hijack the conversation by
making it a union conversation